[Music]
my next guest is a comedian whose new
album hello mr magic plane person hello
debuted at number one on the comedy
charts and who hosts a weekly stand-up
show at meltdown comics in hollywood
please welcome the very funny jonah ray
[Applause]
[Music]
hey everybody how's it going numb what
we're all having fun because you know
why it's the summer no
yeah it's summertime i'm excited for
summertime because the summertime means
pool parties i'm an adult i love pool
parties not so much for the swimming
though because i'm kind of a shirt on in
the pool kind of guy
my body kind of looks like a heroin
addict that's also really into pizza
uh what i like about pool parties is the
uh the most pure joke you could ever do
at any pool party is to push somebody
into the pool who didn't want to go in
the pool
it's all you got to do is this no setup
no punch just this motion and then you
become the king of the party
hell the king is summer really and you
just like because it's the best thing
you push them into the pool and they
didn't want to go in the pool now
they're all wet and that's great thing
is 15 years ago that was a hilarious
joke nowadays you push somebody into the
pool and you ruin their lives pretty
much for the next three weeks
they're like oh man my phone all my
numbers are gone but my ipod all my
songs and have those backed up
my ipad i was writing a novel on my ipad
was gonna be the first guy that did that
now that's all gone
15 years ago you push somebody in the
pool they go oh my la light stop
blinking
[Music]
oh man pass me that crystal pepsi
that's two references two references
right there
i have a tattoo of a penguin on my arm
it's my favorite animal that's why i got
it it'd be weird if it wasn't uh
i love penguins so much so i got the
tattoo and my friend when i got the
tattoo i said hey i got a penguin ted
he's like what you know tattoos last the
rest of your life well i know what a
tattoo is you're condescending jerk
i don't know why i'm friends with him
really and uh
he says were you going to like penguins
for the rest of your life i was like
well yeah
what are penguins going to do
what are penguins going to do that's
going to really mess that up for me
are they going to put out a bad album
i'm gonna go oh the penguins used to be
so good
totally sold out penguins is there gonna
be a time in the future where someone
goes hey hear about those penguins in
south africa no what happened turns out
all of them racist homophobes oh
penguins
i have a mammal swastika on my arm
that's not good
uh i uh i like drinking a lot it's one
of my favorite things to do if you
haven't tried it
if you haven't tried it go for it it is
delightful uh what i like is a good
excuse to drink especially during the
day which is the best time to drink uh i
like daedric a lot and i like a good
excuse because i like you know what i
like a sad friend a sad friend going
through a hard time with a girl is the
best excuse to drink whenever you want
because you could justify that to your
girlfriend like why you're drinking
during the day i was like what am i
supposed to do sheila fake girlfriend i
just made up sheila
why are you up there sheila you're very
tall sheila
what am i supposed to he's my best
friend i'm gonna leave him here by
himself he's going through a hard time
what's that well yeah i got irish car
bombs i got a whole mess of irish car
bombs he needs to disconnect what's that
yeah i got wings his ex-girlfriend never
let him have wings ever wait wait what's
that
i don't know when he's going to get here
when he does he's going to see how good
of a friend i am
the best friend that wants to he wants
to go to mexico
that's right
jonah ray a good friend
uh but i've been that sad friend before
i've been that guy that needs a little
help a little uh uh i've been sad a lot
but uh you know i i constantly fantasize
about uh suicide it's weird it's kind of
a hobby of mine it's a
because doing suicide is not really a
hobby what's a hobby is something you
can only do once i just uh but i
fantasize about it quite often
and i just but like i can never do it so
what i've done is i've written a very
vague suicide note to take with me
wherever i go just in the case that i
die in some crazy way everyone think it
was a planned thing
it's like like i'm walking down the
street and i get hit by lightning and
like i die and then people are like oh
my god they run into my smoldering body
oh my god he got hit by a lining hold on
there's a note
what no way
no way oh man i didn't know he could
control the elements
he's like that thor guy from earlier
that is something always wants to have
the rest
or you could do it the other way you
could just have a note that's uh just
kind of vague where it's uh you know any
way you die be it of natural causes or
an accident or anything it could just
the note can just say no matter what
this looks like it was no accident you
have to avenge my death fly to brussels
tonight
and it's a way to keep on giving after
you've gone
i uh i do before i get out of here it's
i'm gonna take this opportunity to
register a complaint uh if you uh don't
mind uh the store tj maxx now i don't
really care about the story either way
it's more of the fact that they took the
coolest name in the world
tj maxx with two exes t.j you can't say
that tj maxx isn't the coolest name
ever tj maxx should be the name of some
store it should be the name of the
coolest kid we all went to high school
with
we still tell stories about t.j you
remember tjmx i remember tj maxx my best
friend tj maxx remember that one time tj
maxx boned everybody i know
will you let him do it even me i didn't
care tj maxx two exes awesome
remember that one time tj maxx stole the
school then drove it off of a ramp over
five other schools oh man the coolest tj
maxx so much cooler than ross
all right everybody that's enjoying all
right thank you so much
hey hey good job thank you very funny
ladies and gentlemen